oh right let us get to this thing going
yeah hope everyone's doing all right so
far this evening well I get this thing
to behave come yeah that's what I'm
after I have a muffin thing I don't even
know how that started but thing now so
good evening all ah
you made several errors and the player
games review but the only one that got
under my skin was calling the culture a
future society it's not it's an alien
society founded around 8000 BC okay um
I'm gonna chalk that up to the fact that
I didn't read the blog post describing
it because I don't recall that detail
being laid out specifically in that book
which was how I choose to chose to take
it in so while I get that that might
have wrought riled you up a little if
obviously this was a series that meant
something to you I'm pretty sure that
that wasn't covered in the book that I'd
actually read so apologies but that it
just kind of is what it is
awesome yes love ninja unicorns ah did
you read the full story in one of the
past who livestream comments yeah
probably at some point Andrew but like I
don't think you you folks realize how
much of a sieve my brain is sometimes
like it's very arbitrary at times what
sticks and what doesn't just wanted to
say you inspired me to make a channel
and I will be posting videos in December
in January
I've already planned 370 forbids love
your content and you're amazing you are
ambitious my friend and cheers to you
wow I love your glasses yes I like these
glasses actually quite a bit um so Oh
from Brazil so this one it's not really
this livestreams aren't you're really
gonna work any different then they
always have but I am just gonna point
out that I did put it out on the discord
for my patreon supporters if they had
any questions they wanted me to answer
so that they didn't have to just roll
the dice and you know hope that I saw
their question in the chat so that
basically gave them a guaranteed answer
to a question if they had one so I will
be jumping back to reference the discord
internet link to be sure that I cover
all of those
oh wow this is fun to me so Quinn
Sinclair just asked have you watched
Jessica Jones season three last of the
Marvel Netflix I haven't yet um here's
here's the funny thing
uh you're literally the first person to
ask me like I was trying to figure out
how to fit like binging through that
thing in my schedule cuz like people are
gonna expect review from me literally no
one has asked until you that's not to
say I'm not gonna watch it I am but that
to me is a pretty strong read on how
invested people are in that show right
now so it's it's not as high a priority
as it might have otherwise been okay so
this is a question related to the
patreon tiers is the hundred dollars for
book reviews just for novels or any
written work if I want you to read and
review a hundred page source story what
I have to behind your dollars um
the hundred dollar tear is intended to
be a novel length thing so if you wanted
me to read something shorter than that I
would say like hit me up not in the
livestream and let me like get a sense
of what it is we're talking about and we
can probably negotiate a price that is
less than that but the the hundred
dollars is intended to be an review of a
written work that is novel length so
that's the the theory behind that at
least people are saying glitchy is that
everybody or just a few people do I have
to pay 100 dollars for you to read this
message oh crap
you would have but I blew it you got it
for free so dant uh not Glee's for me
not good she at all okay cool well we
got Gryffindor's in the house
coming through fine okay it looks like
most people have it okay awesome shirt
where'd you get it
this is this was an Amazon purchase and
this was bought actually specifically in
solidarity because I have a friend who
she's doing pretty well now but she
she's been battling cancer for a couple
years now and she sort of started a
whole thing like her friends sort of it
was like team ninja corn was like the
whole getting behind her to try and
doing what we could to help her through
it so while it wasn't necessarily based
around this t-shirt that whole thing
when I saw this I'm like I'm getting
that and she was the first person who
got to see it so that's that's where
this originated from probably not going
to ask you to review another book for
months probably Christmas that's
actually appreciated because I'm already
working on a book review of a book that
is even longer than player games was so
I'm actually I've got I've got my
reading set out for me for a little bit
so that's appreciated house Slytherin
your snakes represent much love to your
ninja corn friend thank you very much oh
we got the hufflepuffs here in the UK
there's a news article showing a boy
dressed up in drag and he won prom queen
caused controversy obviously thoughts I
mean in my mind it's only an issue if
like a woman in a tux wasn't allowed to
be considered for prom king so I don't
know if that was even applicable like it
might not have been the Kate like it
this might have been the only person
presenting not as the gender they were
assigned at Birth like on paper I'm
totally fine with it as long as it
wasn't being done as like oh this is
cute but like other stuff is we're not
gonna treat it equally but you know I
don't know enough details I can't say
but basic premise I'm I'll support that
sorry I'm late have I missed anything no
not really
I do you enjoy gin I don't mind gin um
hasn't really been my thing I'm had a
number of friends who like gin was their
go-to thing I'm agents fine I mean the
thing is like there's no one particular
liquor that I'm like that um generally
speaking my go-to is hard cider
I like ciders a lot but as far as like a
harder liquor you know I'm I'm a mixer
I'm a cocktail person so I'm just more
likely to look at what's on hand and
make something up on the fly because I
used to bartend
once upon a time uh today is Eric Carles
90th birthday very cool folks don't know
Eric Carles children's author best known
for the hungry little caterpillar one of
my favorite children's authors of all
time and he's still publishing books of
this very day awesome
whiskey is my go-to but I do like
cocktails yeah I used to do you know I
used to um huh
wild turkey was my go-to like cue like
12 years ago but I don't really do
straight liquor anymore
do I know who etiquette is only from the
news story that came out I I didn't know
anything about him prior to that but I
am aware for folks who who missed it
it's a he I guess he's a gaming a you
tour was gaming youtuber who had gone
missing and and unfortunately his his
body was found what is your favorite
Buffy's opana lost it ah got backup what
is your favorite Buffy Season no
spoilers for season seven I'm on Stevens
season 7 episode 9 and ah um well it's
not steven season 7
it is a really tough call for me if
we're talking season between two and
three because I'm kind of of the opinion
that two has some of the best single
episodes and a really good overall story
progression but there's some hiccup
episodes in it as well
season three I think is probably the
strongest overall and has the strongest
series our continuity over the entirety
of the season so I feel like that's a
stronger product taking the season as a
whole as opposed to you know
cherry-picking episodes more but I go
back and forth between those two they're
both really really good um it's not to
say I completely crap on the later
seasons because some people do like I
actually like season six quite a bit the
season seven as I said look well you do
you have the finale to look forward to
the actual finale I think it's great a
lot of the rest of season seven is a bit
iffy but ya know no spoilers liquor but
I don't know her consent
remember my friends consent is sexy and
mandatory if I pay $100 for you to read
another novel could it be any length
asked you to be player of games because
he told me I could pick a culture novel
under 300 pages um I mean you say any
length if you're about to if you're
gonna try and Commission me to read I
don't know the on the uncut version of
Stephen King's The Stand I'm probably
gonna probably gonna want a premium on
that so like the the base level thinking
on that right now
is in the 300 page range if you're
talking significantly shorter or
significantly longer like I said hit me
up outside of the livestream we'll
figure it out
thoughts on the Final Fantasy 7 remake
finally coming out I don't really have
any because I don't have a modern I
don't have a current gen system so I'm
not gonna be able to play it and I don't
have a PC that would be able to run it
so
like I'm never gonna play it so I don't
really care and I can't
I mean Squaresoft
and I say that because before it became
square enix made some of my all-time
favorite games Square Enix is not the
same company squaresoft once was in
terms of their approach to games and a
lot of other stuff so I just I don't
know I it's hard for me to get it I mean
like again part of it is I don't game
current-gen but it's hard for me even
though I pay attention to what's going
on and get me to get psyched by a lot of
what's going on besides the fact I've
always been of the opinion that I'd much
rather see proper preservation of old
games rather than remakes of them
especially if you're gonna redo the
mechanics from the ground up like if
they just wanted to juice up the visuals
yeah Final Fantasy 7 visuals like most
early polygon graphics have not aged
well
like at all but like they completely
revamp the combat system and I just I
don't want I don't really want it
besides the fact that I actually think
Final Fantasy 7 is overrated because
it's so good don't get me wrong but it a
lot of the series's bad habits that
became endemic of Final Fantasy as a
property after seven they started
happening in seven how incomprehensible
the stories became being kind of the big
one for me since I'm kind of a story
focused person in general uh for God's
sake I have fallen behind on this I'm so
excited for holidays because I'm finally
able to catch two full live streams in a
row whoo nice to have you here uh how's
your weekend going you you you say that
present tense like I'm currently in the
weekend my weekend past was fine five
$8,100 will you read before
peace ah hmm
a favorite video game of all time that's
Final Fantasy 6 is my favorite of all
time I have replayed that more than any
other game do you have you ever in ever
played The Sims like I fiddled with it
it's not the kind game that is normally
my thing like I like I like something a
bit more linear I like to have a goal
I'm not the kind of person who can just
kind of futz around in a game and get
much enjoyment out of it a favor I'm
Monty Python movie Life of Brian I was
talking about your current week damn
autocorrect yeah I know
autocorrect is the bane of my existence
sometimes it seriously is so uh hang on
I'm gonna jump back to the discord and
grab the first of those questions that I
got from my patron so let's see if you
had to pick someone to play a green
lantern on film which one and whose so
which green lantern and who would I have
to play it I'd want to go John Stuart
because at this point I think Hal Jordan
needs to be rested aside from the fact
that like characterization wise I think
he I don't think how's the most unique
guy in the world and I think there's
there's more to be done with someone
like John Stuart hello kyle rayner would
be solid except I don't I don't think
you can start with Kyle Rayner
I think Kyle Rayner works a lot better
as a replacement for whoever was a more
traditional feeling Green Lantern I
think if you're not gonna do Hal Jordan
which I don't think they should right
now Jon Stewart's a good call for that
no guy Garvin is not even in contention
and I'll talking about Guy Gardner but
who would I have I like I hope I get his
name his first two names of the right
order John David Washington
so that's Denzel Washington's son who
starred in black Klansmen
he would be my pick to play John Stewart
you could go older than him he's in his
early 30s you could go early 40s if you
wanted but like I kinda I kind of like
that sort of on the tail end of the of
the ideal sort of military age because
Jon Stewart has that background so that
that that would be my my own pick for
that loved your recent community post
you look fantastic thank you very much
a new member any recommendations for me
to binge or read while I'm sick in the
hospital I don't know what you like so
you got to give me more to work with
than that you think that Ryan Gosling
could play another Green Lantern like
Hal guy are the first human Green
Lantern I Ryan Gosling is fine like I
he's one of those guys are like he's
fine I just don't quite get the hype if
you were in one of DC's Lantern cores
which color would you be Oh God can I
even remember all the lantern court
colors okay so there's green for
willpower oranges avarice yellow is fear
red is rage indigo I don't even remember
what that is violet blue black is death
white is life collect um I don't know
like I didn't really read much of the
Lantern core stuff so I don't know like
how fully they are supposed to embody
the emotion that is driving things for
each color so I mean I don't know on a
bad day I could go either orange or red
do you think it's time Russell T Davies
came back to write an episode has been
years in his domestic and comedic style
would work well with current artists
team I
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna give two
answers to that the first is I would be
down for seeing him right
another story however that should not
happen when there is so much division in
the fan base over the current direction
of things because if he were to come in
and write an episode now like in safe
for series 12 or she was 15 with chip no
still in place and Whittaker still there
it's just gonna cause this massive fan
uproar of people going oh we should
bring him back you get rid of chip no
dude like regardless of whether or not
he'd do it better like that's just a
level of drama that I for one don't want
to deal with I'm pretty sure the people
who producing the show don't want to
deal with it's one of those things where
like even if you wrote something good
the just the the climate is not right
for that which pains me to say I loved
your deadline review so glad you enjoyed
the story I did that was that was heavy
I bet I've been commissioned for a
number of heavy things lately though
I've got a review coming out next week
that for some of them very heavy how
much of Jessica Jones Season three have
you seen at present
none 451 pages but not until 2020 okay
like I said we'll talk offline
we'll talk off the off the livestream
you can you can email me you can hit me
up do the messenger function on patreon
and you know what we'll get it okay
indigo is compassion purple and pink is
love I would be Indigo tribe okay I had
most of them though uh okay here are
your Russell T Davies come and wins
there's a reason I watch you thank you
kindly excited for stranger things
season 3 I just finished season 2 no I'm
nervous cuz I did not like season 2 very
much so no I am just there renourish for
that
I'm also similarly similarly similarly
be nervous for Jessica Jones season -
I'm sorry season 3 because I didn't like
season 2 of that either
should dr. whoever crossover with
another show if so what um no I'm not
the thing is unless they're designed to
exist within the same space like say the
air / shows I'm not big on show
crossovers like they just know I kind of
pass like I wouldn't mind an Easter Egg
sort of crossover like if if we saw red
dwarf in the background of a shot or
something that'd be cool like that's
kind of how that it crosses over with a
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
franchise it's a little Easter Egg II
things like I'm down for that but like a
proper the doctor meets now mmm pass
I'd only commissioned another novel
review before Christmas if I came into
some money before then so if I
Commissioner another review before
Christmas my grandfather died Oh God
okay now now that's that's depressing
and sad scooby-doo meets Doctor Who
alright I would want to see that as a
half hour animated I don't know which
doctor Oh should totally be the 12th
doctor and because he's like a grumpy
old man they automatically assume that
he's gonna be the face that they see
when they pull the mask off whatever
thing they're going after okay that I
want to see but I'd like it needs to be
a from the scooby-doo end not the Doctor
Who end cuz that's the thing about
crossovers whenever you do a crossover
ultimately
it you can't do a proper 50/50 split
it's always one of them appearing in the
other ones story so like there was
recently the not recently the last year
I guess the Batman in the Scooby Doo
that was very much a Scooby Doo thing
with Batman more recently there was a
Batman and the t's Ninja Turtles thing
which I haven't seen yet but I want to
that's very much
man thing with the Ninja Turtles in it
so if it was a scooby-doo thing with
Doctor Who okay yeah I do kind of want
to see that now Doctor Who is linked
that to that continuum of shows that by
virtue all the crossovers all exist with
Oh God yeah the tummy white fall
universe like that that was interesting
um like when it first got proposed but
at this point it's gotten so bizarre and
expansive like I don't even find it
interesting anymore to me doctor who's
too unique for a crossover almost the
same feeling I have with gravity falls
and Rick and Morty okay fair enough
yes I love Scooby natural yeah I did
hear about that uh someone needs to make
that if immediately I think we just
pitched a thing like somebody's somebody
dial in the BBC or Pegasus Warner
Brothers on the Scooby Doo we need a
Shrek crossover with Shrek as the master
oh no I like I'll actually defend the
first two Shrek movies but no we're
gonna watch Batwoman when it comes out
right when it comes out probably not
because I don't I don't have a live TV I
did they cut the cord thing all I've got
a streaming services so and I don't have
all of them so I'll see it eventually
I'm sure would you want Joss Whedon to
write a Doctor Who episode not really
like I feel like his general
sensibilities are not that far off from
day visas and I like I like Whedon but
I'm not sure I want his sensibilities
kind of layered over something like
Doctor Who black mirror Doctor Who cross
over um I would like Charlie Brooker to
take a crack at writing a Doctor Who
episode like that would I'd be down for
that
proper cross over them now although
again like in an easter-egg way like if
a piece of tech from Black Mirror were
to pop up innocuously and a Doctor Who
things like I don't know we saw like one
of the dogs from metalhead like just
walk across a table or something and
like uh like in some location at that
that'd be cool I find I find
entertaining that my mother would
probably be pissed at me for thinking
but I thought about it and that seems
like the most possible way I'd have
disposable income in less than six
months look like that take your time I'm
not going anywhere so don't sweat it too
much would you want to see yesterday it
looks quite cute um I'm not like that
rings the vaguest bell I'm not sure what
I can't pull it into my head though what
yesterday is so I'm gonna need you to
help me out there Meg Stargate doctor
who Ross over yesterday is the movie
about the Beatles I okay I guess they
saw something about that a while back I
don't know enough about it like you're
very very vague it's it's like somewhere
they're like I don't really know a lot
about it um do you watch the 100 I do
not so yeah in a world where no one
knows who the Beatles are a guy becomes
popular by seeing their songs I already
like seeing some kind of trailer or
something
I don't know it did it obviously didn't
leave um much of an impression so I'm
gonna jump back to the discord real
quick grab another patreon question
let's see if you could pick any past
companion to make at least a cameo
appearance this year's twelve who would
it be and why like I could make an
argument for any number of companions
but my brain immediately
to ace I would love for ace to turn up
and just she has to have the baseball
bat like I don't I don't so I don't care
how old Sophie Allred is I still want
her to have that baseball back and the
boom box ideally but I just I love ace I
think ace is fantastic and I would love
to see how she how somebody as raucous
as her would bounce off of whippet occur
I would I would be very curious to see
that Martha and Mickie that would work
it was a movie on Netflix called see you
yesterday I believe it's very good and
combines racism and bullying with
time-travel elements I hadn't heard that
one finally finished my first read of
Good Omens and I feel that I'd love to
reread it soon
I should reread that cuz I have read the
book but I read it like 20 years ago
it's been a while uh what do you think
about the whole super wholock thing I
know about wholock super who logged is
new to me is that like combining
supernatural in with it um I've never
seen supernatural so like I don't really
have an opinion on its integration or
anything else sorry folks I just don't
I've got to get Good Omens oh yeah it's
a great read
did you ever read stand on Zanzibar nope
don't know what that is
would you want the doctor's daughter to
come back I know you didn't like the
episode she appeared in so the idea of
Jenny coming back into Doctor Who I'm
not gonna say that I think it's
automatically a bad idea
I do feel like in a lot of ways if there
was a time to do that it's past we've
gone through to complete regeneration
cycles without her coming back so I like
I I'm not like I feel like the window
may have closed on not like logistical
II like you could justify bringing her
back as far as the logistics goes but
like if there was a point in time to do
it I feel I feel like we missed it um
that said like if somebody had like a
really strong story that she would work
in I I'm I wouldn't say that they
shouldn't do it but you know if the
whole idea is just Andrew Byrne Jenny
back ok what's the story she's back like
no I don't I don't care I think that
kind of story with the doctor groundhog
days already exists correct me if I'm
wrong yeah that's basically heaven-sent
more or less Oh Lord of Hugh er on
tumblr during away tumblr during during
like 2013 super wholock was everywhere
like I said I only ever picked up on who
lock I missed the the super end of it I
like tumblr tumblr was never something I
got into heavily I was on it off and on
for a few years I kind of abandoned it
in solidarity when they when they swung
the the no dough content hammer cuz
there are a lot of creators and artists
especially whose work I admired and who
I got completely basically got
completely shut out of their primary
platform by that and just out of out of
spite and solidary I was kind of like
well
kind of done with this thing now so I
have I haven't been back on tumblr you
know other than like if somebody sent me
a link to look at something specific
I'll do that but like as a thing in
general I'm kind of done with it
have you seen any of the arrowverse TV
shows um yes so alright I have seen two
seasons of flash 2 and a bit seasons of
Supergirl
three seasons of legends of tomorrow no
seasons of arrow I've only seen that
crew in the crossovers and I guess Black
Lightning even though it's on the CW
doesn't count in that so and I've seen
like half of half a season of that so
not I'm not up to date on any of them
the only one I want to be current on is
ledges Oh tomorrow because the others I
either had no interest in from the start
or they eventually did something to
annoy me uh-huh
tomber is the place where civil
discussions go to die I never got stuck
into it enough to really get that end of
it I have heard that though this is
incredibly important who would win in a
fight but ting vs. absorbable off versus
the flood think very carefully it's
difficult I'm not sure that it is
because the nature of the flood is to
completely rewrite the DNA of whatever
it infects so even like with something
like the patina that can theoretically
digest anything or something like the
absorb aloft which can absorb things
into it it's gonna rewrite them from the
inside out I think the flood takes it
without a heck of a lot of like I can
get I get why you might think that it
might be a bit of a struggle but like I
don't think so
Legends is my fave
I'm just watching them all now I like I
love legends
I think legends is so much fun and I
love those characters I love Sarah Sarah
is great but I love
make make is the blast this huge gruff
guy who just gives everybody these
condescending nicknames and oh I love
that he he meets Supergirl and he's like
I'm gonna call you skirt na ponytail
such a jerk but he loved him so much
the flood was the scariest of the three
well yeah that's that's not even a
question
favorite Milani Python skit Oh move
individual skit I'm not oh yeah I'm not
even sure cuz there's a lot of really
great ones that one I have to think
about bebo is to be worshipped yes hail
bebo VR exists in the culture series but
it's mainly presented as an option for
people want to experience a life that
the rest of the college culture would
consider deviant I mean that's a nice
decent way to handle that um basically
hand people uh what uh what amounts to a
holodeck and say go nuts
who's it hurting uh are you waiting for
the next book of A Song of Ice and Fire
no cuz I haven't read any of them I was
severely intimidated by those books
ladies just because of the number of
characters I mean I had a hard enough
time keeping charge of the show in its
first year or two and honestly the only
reason I was able to do it at all is I
have a much better memory for faces than
I do names so when I was watching the
show Game of Thrones it I wouldn't
always remember characters names but I'd
be like okay I know that face and I saw
that face from here and I know he's his
relationship to these characters is this
but names are harder for me they don't
stick as well and like there are just so
many characters and when it's on the
page all I have to go by is a name and
if I don't remember it I'm just gonna
I'll have to keep flipping back or I
know there's a glossary in the back but
that breaks up the flow so bad the idea
that I would have to keep referring to a
glossary
I didn't I didn't love the idea I mean
at this point having having seen Game of
Thrones I would actually know who these
characters were by name so I can
probably get through it better now but I
don't know I just haven't I don't have
the drive to do it
opinion on the youtuber Bullis strike um
I I don't watch his channel and I will
leave it at that and I would ask out of
civility that other folks leave it at
that too
if you can nobody expects the Spanish
Inquisition weapon is surprise rise in
fear fear and surprise are two weapons
oh yeah I know stuff way too well Game
of Thrones prequel I mean until I see
until I see a trailer like okay get the
comfy yeah I'm more excited about the
Lord of the Rings TV series in the
witcher i'm curious about the witcher
The Lord of the Rings like I I mean I
don't doubt it'll be good but that is
one of those key pieces right we kind of
got the definitive you know
visualization live-action of that story
and I don't know how you do it different
in a way that feels valid I mean I just
I just don't and that's not me saying
the Lord of the Rings movies are perfect
they're not but like I just I don't know
how you do more than just vaguely tweak
it quick there's a weepy a little behind
you yeah there always is don't worry
about it I've got the camera watching it
we have hahaha we have no need of comfy
chairs I got them say comfy chairs
hi I'm that one that one a hole who
doesn't like Lord of the Rings
well like truth be told I don't really
care for the books that much because
Tolkien's writing could get very dry and
actually trying to read the books is not
always that much fun to be honest I do
prefer the movies biologic but you're
also not required to like them if that's
that's not I'm not gonna be gay keeping
on yeah don't worry about it I kind of
want a Harry Potter sequel TV show with
his son in Hogwarts yeah I think if you
were gonna do any kind of a continuation
of Harry Potter that is based in
Hogwarts which I mean I think is
something that makes a heck of a lot
more sense than fantastic beasts does I
think the best thing to do would be
television so that we were dealing with
like season-long you know a year at
Hogwarts being a full season of
television and that would cuz that what
that would largely get us to be able to
do is to revel in the sort of stuff that
had to become for the movies because a
lot of what was come for the movies was
the day-to-day classroom stuff and that
is a pretty big part of just the feel
and the flavor you get from those books
so like I think the idea of a TV show or
honestly even if they were going to just
adapt the books as they exist again
doing it as a TV show makes a lot more
sense to me
whereas with Lord of the Rings there
wasn't that much that was lost in the
translation like it was anybody really
missing Tom Bombadil that much I mean
I'm sorry but striking Viper's do you
think it's this man it could really
spend so much time in a woman's body and
not freak out I I mean I'm not a system
and so I have no idea I mean I think a
lot of it just has to do with how strong
your own sense of self is
so like for lack of a better comparison
you know you'll meet guys who are you
know straight but there are straight
guys who will get really weird even in
the presence of a gay person like it's
some like even being friendly with them
is somehow a threat to their masculinity
or their straightness but you'll have
others who would just like treat them
like anyone else and I think that is
just a like an easy very rough
approximation of what I mean by strong
in their sense of self so if the nature
of a sis male in terms of his gender
identities is if he's truly firmly
secure in that no I don't think he would
necessarily be freaked out by it did we
just be a different experience didn't
you read the cursed child that didn't
didn't turn out well well no it didn't
but the reason the curse child didn't
turn out well wasn't because it was
about the younger generation the reason
the curse child didn't turn out well is
because they were trying to force a
novel style story into a play format
which didn't make a lot of sense and
they also broke their own time-travel
rules that had been previously
established it was sloppily written it
wasn't an inherently better well and
also they forced the involvement of bull
de mort again can we move on from this
freaking guide can we ever be done
fighting him if but if it was just a
continuation of you know the next
generation of kids I think there's a
validity to that and just because it
didn't work in the curse child doesn't
mean the concept is flawed it just means
the execution of that specific thing
didn't really work
worst movie experience you ever had um I
don't know off the top of my head I can
tell you though the first movie that I
remember hating like there were movies
that I didn't like before this but the
first movie I remember hating was Jim
Jarmusch's movie dead man I hated that
had his head so far up its own butt I
was in high school I was like at the
perfect age to just absorb the
pretension and feel smart for it but I
hated it so much
do you prefer practical effects or CGI
and Lord of the Rings type movies
impractical I mean if you can do
practical you can get the practical to
the practical like CGI in my mind should
only ever be employed when the practical
is impractical but like practical things
should be the default they just should
they look better and CGI should be
reserved for when you're doing something
that you cannot do otherwise
which is how CGI used to be used when
used well like you think back to
something like Terminator 2 or Jurassic
Park and young mud most of the shots in
Jurassic Park those are practical
puppets it's only on the shots where
that was not viable that they used CGI
is the n64 functional yeah it is I'm I
haven't used it in a bit but 20 months
ago or so last time I turned it on
worked then Lord of the Rings the
musical um I'd be vaguely curious
especially considering that there are
enough songs in those stories to
actually not even have to write that
much original stuff I would prefer to
see a spin-off based on the founders of
Hogwarts what do you think ah no I I'm
not saying it couldn't work but like
that that wouldn't that doesn't trigger
any interest in me have you ever watched
tremors I have that's what I've seen the
first three tremors films that's a fun
series
it's very dumb but it's it's
surprisingly well written for being dumb
ah there actually is the Lord of the
Rings musical it was only performed in
Canada in London huh
when like when does it date from because
for my money this is probably either
done to try and cash in on the movies
herbs from the 70s and now I'm curious
CJ I mix with practical effects is the
best way to go look at the behind the
scenes of Mad Max fury road I mean
that's a great example like nearly
everything there was done practical
primarily if not exclusively I mean down
to the frigging flame-throwing guitar
that was a practical effect but they'd
like slightly enhance it they'd remove
Cape guide cables that were used to
ensure that the cars were going the way
that they need they removed tracks with
CGI late 2000s okay so it was cashing in
on the movies before the movies turn of
the millennia so well that would have
been right around the time of the movies
first when we came out in 2001 folks I
do you realize how old these movies are
at this point ah The Hobbit as well I
think I knew that I think I knew that
one is it fair to say that anyone can be
cast as a companion but not everyone can
be cast as the doctor well yeah with the
asterisks asterisk assuming they can act
wertha Dane um see I'm not sure I'd say
that because like a big part of like my
one my personal one restriction that I
in my mind for casting doctors it has to
be someone from the UK and that is
because I fear that moving outside that
especially if they were cast American
that the show will start to lose its
very British identity and approach which
is a big part of its charm for me um and
I would worry about that with them with
American companions as well so
like I do I really kind of do think the
core cast kind of needs to be from those
Islands would you prefer to see the
Marauders and Lily get a story that
would be cashing in that would be
catching a part of Harry's story I don't
I mean maybe I just linked a clip of the
musical to your Twitter I don't check
that out after the live stream is over
if you had a chance would you rather
play the doctor or a companion like
first of all like to be clear based on
my criteria
I would never cast be setting that aside
I would want to crack at the doctor that
that would be my preference because I
have an ego like that so jump it back to
the discord real quick um have you seen
any trailers or teasers or promos in the
last week or so that have hyped you for
whatever the property is uh not really I
think just the fact that I cannot
remember if I've seen any trailers or
teasers for the first time in the last
week or so that was kind of my answer to
that and oddly enough when I stop and
think about it like I feel like teasers
and trailers lately have been kind of
leaving me cold in general I can't
remember the last time that one got me
like really pumped I think it might have
been endgame and even that that was
largely on the strength of what had been
built up by that franchise I cannot
remember the last time a teaser like
really made me go maybe sit up and pay
attention
it's maybe us but even that feels like
an outlier marketing stuff doesn't do
much for me these days I don't know if
I'm just getting too jaded for it to
work anymore I'm too cynical to be
marketed to Oh God I'm still waiting for
the Tom Hooper Cats trailer oh Lord
I forgot they're doing a movie of cats
oh man why was that a thing why is it
still like what I will never understand
the pill I've never met a single human
being who likes that show like I've
known people who like a couple of songs
I don't know anyone who actually likes
that thing and like I know a lot of
theater people like that those those
were my people like especially through
high school college like I don't know
anyone who likes cats I I don't I don't
I don't get it
do you think it would be better in
Doctor Who if Amy and Rory left at the
end of series six and series series
seven is only with Clara I don't think
the point at which Clara comes in is the
reason she doesn't work the reason she
doesn't work is because the version of
Clara that we got they didn't bother to
characterize her the Osmond and the
Victorian governess versions of Clara
are much better characterized in the one
episodes they appear and then Clara is
for her entire half a series in series
seven so the issue was not that she only
got have a series the issue was she was
uncharacterized and she was a plot
device not a character for that entire
first stretch of her run that's why she
didn't work she got better later than
hellbent happened
hey hold on I missed something here I
just experienced déjà vu some of you
said set my brain off with it I saw
somebody recently the might have been
somebody retweeted on Twitter
what if deja vu happens because you died
and you just reloaded your last save I
found that to be amusing
have you seen origins of the air no
that's the fan film a Harry Potter fan
to film right thank I know I haven't
Clara as a teacher was amazing and
relatable yeah
Clara's a teacher was solid like Clara
Clara started to feel like a proper
character in series 8 and she also had
much better chemistry with Capaldi than
she had was Smith she grew on me over
time but she had a rough start man she
really did did 11 pick up another Clara
fragment after name of the doctor Clara
suddenly had a new job and relationships
in a new area of town I mean like there
was also a time jump so like I was
prepared to roll with that I didn't that
didn't bother me so much no disrespect
to Jody I enjoy her but wish Bradley
Wallace was the doctor and Jody was a
companion I've seen more than a few
people say that I do like Bradley Walsh
ena I'm not sure I see doctor in him but
then again if he was playing the doctor
maybe you wouldn't be playing at the
same as Graham so I don't know why do
theater people and music people hate
each other because they both want all
the credit music people want all the
focus to be on the lyrics and the notes
and theater people want all the focus to
be on the performance to the presence
and they just butt heads yeah like
theatre people especially like we're
attention-seeking and you know when just
some dude with an acoustic guitar is
hogging the attention we get salty I
also nominate a younger Angela
Lansbury's the doctor heck with that I
want Angela Lansbury right now is the
doctor she's still kicking let her do it
did you watch Batman animated movie mask
of the phantasm I own it so yes I have
I've seen that I like I like I said I'm
I haven't seen the latest few DC
Animated but like Auton all the older
ones I've seen you know the the Batman
Beyond line return of the Joker the Sub
Zero mask of the phantasm like I've seen
all these things I own a chunk of them
is that coffee not cold yet uh
it's it's not warm anymore but it's
still very tasty
Angela would be amazing yes she would
Angelo has very doctor whom he's Jessica
Fletcher sidenote loving the glasses
shirt and hair overall look is great
today thank you very much
extermination she wrote did you watch
whose line is it anyway yeah I used to
back in the day I forget what um channel
used to marathon it might have been
Comedy Central liked it when it had dead
time he would marathon that like back in
the day yeah that was good stuff like
the British version like the original
British version yeah it's real good
have you seen return of the Joker oh
yeah
I love how after everything the Joker's
done he can't handle being the punchline
like I really love return of the Joker I
think it's phenomenal I find for me
personally I think it might be my
favorite of the animated DC things it's
really really good
are you watching The Joker with Joaquin
Phoenix or birds of prey I mean probably
when they come out I'm curious about
both like the the Joker one especially
like it's gonna be really hard it's like
a tiny bull's eye where that works but
if they can hit it it's gonna be dang
impressive like I feel like going to
that movie is is gonna be like watching
a daredevil trying to jump a gorge on a
motorcycle it's like I don't think you
can actually pull this off but if you do
it's gonna be amazing
I love all the iterations of whose line
yeah like I've never seen a bad
iteration of whose line largely because
they pretty much all have Ryan Stiles
and Colin Mochrie and you can't really
go wrong
what I said about the culture being
totally alien society does that take you
out of sci-fi stories aliens being
identical to humans
um no but I think if I had known that
they were an alien society yet they
basically are indistinguishable from
humans you know aside from you know the
things that they have developed over
time like the like the like the glands
and whatnot that might have bothered me
a little bit because if they're just
visually going to be the same as humans
then why do they need to be eight like
my question I'm not necessarily saying
it's a bad thing and it wouldn't
necessarily take me out of it but part
of me would be wondering why
what does then what does it being an
alien society add if functionally and
visually they're the same as humans I
mean I'm sure a lot of it probably ties
into the backstory in history of the
culture and all that stuff but you know
yes Quinn that that is like that is one
of my favorite moments from from return
of the Joker that you just quoted okay I
gotta jump back and get some more of the
questions from the discord let's see uh
what movie book TV show comic etc
started you down the geekdom path and
why um was probably Star Wars my mother
introduced me to Star Wars when I was
three my uncle had HBO and so he taped
the original trilogy onto VHS off of HBO
for me or for her because she actually
loves Star Wars and then she introduced
it to me on those old VHS second-hand
VHS taped off HBO introduced in three
years like I've been watching stars for
so long I do not remember watching Star
Wars for the first time
I did I don't remember
so like that that would that was the
start I think very firmly that and and I
also saw Ghostbusters when I was
probably four so that probably
solidified it have you seen the Orville
first few episodes was fun I really
should get back to it
I haven't the Orville is awesome ya know
it seemed pretty good I'm dreading the
new Star Wars film I
I mean I'm curious I have reasons to be
skeptical because there's mu sorry um I
have a lot of issues with the last Jedi
but as I've noted they're not the issues
that the most vocal detractors of that
movie have so like it puts me a weird
position um but I'm gonna give it a shot
even if it turns out really good it's
not going to raise my assistent
assessment of the last Jedi probably but
you know well we'll see what we get I
have a strong suspicion that by the time
this new trilogy is done I I'm gonna
have a main core issue which was
something that I actually have been
afraid was gonna be the case of you up
for these even before force awakens came
out I don't want to say what it is cuz I
kind of want to hold on to it in case um
I turn out to be right but we'll see man
your mom let you watch Star Wars and
ghostbusters as a kid I'm just I mean
let she introduced them to me she also
introduced me to the Rocky Horror
Picture Show when I was 13 I like my
mother she she's a cool lady
uh what do you think it would take for
the BBC to get Christopher Eccleston to
play nine um well I guess my first
question is are any of the people who he
holds his grudge against still at the
BBC because and the reason I ask is
because at this point
I'm wondering is it about the specific
people who did him wrong when he was on
Doctor Who or is it just the BBC as an
entity I don't know which is the case
and if it's if it's the latter that's
misguided to me if it's the former then
it we may have he may not do it until
they are gone and that's not me saying
like fire them but like you know if
somebody don't want to work with is
there maybe you don't go back to me
there wasn't enough reloj in the last
Jedi I said it don't at me I mean like I
kylo Ren for me is by far the most
interesting character but I also feel
like they kind of the most of the
characters I feel like they brought
their arcs actually kind of to a close
at the end of the last Jedi which is
part of why I'm nervous for the next one
I think banks did it that way so we
wouldn't think as utopia was achievable
for us it was what he wanted not what he
thought would be I mean that's an
interesting enough angle and logically
that makes sense but I mean I have a
feeling that if people were gonna read
it that way they still would you know
because it's even if it's an alien
society's gonna be read allegorically as
a parallel to human society unless he
ever actually establishes what earth and
humans are up to I don't know if he ever
did I'm over Star Wars but I'm only
seeing 9b yeah because out of obligation
I am actually curious about what 9 is
gonna be I'm not excited I'm not even
sure if I'm hopeful but I am curious
I remember when Rocky Horror came out
but I didn't get to it until the
eighties yeah yeah let's see I've got a
couple more from the discord which
coming which upcoming MCU movie or show
are you most excited for or nervous
about I mean a most nerve
is for the Eternals for two reasons the
first is I know absolutely nothing about
the stuff that they're basing it on but
pretty sure the Eternals was Jack Kirby
and Jack Kirby's cosmic stuff could get
really obtuse so that's gonna put them
in a case where somebody really needs to
be able to mold that and I hope that
they're able to do it and give us
something good and also the rumor is
that the first like like main kind of
character who's gonna be lgbtq+ is gonna
be in the eternal so I'm gonna be
nervous for it for that reason too
excited um uh guardians of the galaxy
three we're probably a minimum three
years off from that one but yeah it's
it's gonna happen and that's probably
the one I'm I'm most excited for I think
that is the last of my patreon questions
yep cool so I got all those done didn't
know about Rocky Horror until college
well it wasn't until college when I
finally got to a midnight showing um
she's splash a little myself but I knew
the movie well before then my father's
friend introduced me to the fourth
doctor back when I was about 10 or so
don't waste the coffee yeah no
definitely don't I know putting quotes
there is coffee in here among other
things
aren't they remaking rocky hard did I
dream that you sort of dreamed it they
did one of those live show things with
it like they did with Sound of Music in
Greece and Jesus Christ Superstar and
Peter Pan and a bunch of others that
happened a couple years ago so that that
already happened
never waste coffee anticipation did the
older doctor who also have the the women
comedians wanting to bang the doctor no
that is purely an invention of modern
era who like to give you an idea of how
a sexual doctor who was it was a massive
deal like and the fans were pissed off
in the 1996 TV movie with Paul McGann
when the doctor kissed it the companion
like that caused an uproar so yeah no
that's totally a modern everything he
did the short story I was thinking about
them discovering earth in 1977 also he
explicitly stated in that blog earth
humans aren't capable of this fair
enough again I skipped the blog cuz it
was a bit too dry and I like to get
these things from context of a narrative
so you know I think we just approach it
differently as readers my parents
wouldn't even let me watch the
masturbation episode of Seinfeld Rocky
Horror would have been out of the
question but here's the thing like my
mother very much was of the opinion that
she was much more concerned about me
watching things that were violent than
things that were sexual so like I was
seeing you know things that had
relatively casual low-level amounts of
nudity or cursing and from a fairly
young age and she was like
you understand don't repeat those words
right I'm like yeah she didn't care if I
saw breasts cuz she's not a Persian she
doesn't think there's anything wrong
with them so she was way more concerned
about me seeing violence stuff on
legends that I dream that sorry was gay
um I don't remember that coming up again
though I haven't seen the latest season
so I'm not I'm not up to date try to
remember when we let our kiddo watch
Rocky Horror definitely before teens
cool didn't Tom Baker date the woman
that played with one of his commands he
married Lalla Ward who played the second
version of Romana that did not last long
and they were still on the show together
when they were breaking up their early
stuff together you can feel the crackle
in the pop of the chemistry but even
that like it's an undercurrent it's not
explicitly that the two of them are
hooking up in the show like the doctor
and Romana I get the vibe because you
know the actors were but it wasn't don't
move it into the narrative why are
parents cool with letting kids see
violence but not a woman's boobs or sex
just cultural hang-ups and also it's uh
it varies country by country so like
this is second hand that I gave that I
knows but like by and large violence in
like film and whatever some is is much
more closely monitored in places like
Europe whereas nudity and things like
that they don't fret as much about where
as in America we have we're still
shaking off the very puritanical roots
in the foundation of our country and
we got we got some hang-ups over here
it's it's embarrassing sometimes
honestly have you ever watched Candyman
I have not I did know that there is
gonna be either a remake or continuation
I'm not entirely sure what it is I did
hear that but no I haven't seen the
original America's kind of puritanical
when it comes to sex
kinda we have frigging parts of this
country that have abstinence only
education as if as if teenagers hormones
are suddenly gonna stop telling them to
have sex if you don't explain to them
what sex actually is now some be
advocating that teenagers should have
sex but for God's sake they should
understand what the hell the mechanics
are have to be watched in the end you
haven't watched Indiana Jones no I've
never heard of it please describe for me
this Jones from Indiana of which you
speak sarcasm
and that's the end of that which is
usually like you to wrap things up
conversion therapy Oh God yeah I'm not
even gonna get started by that path but
yeah so I think I'm gonna wrap it up
there oh yeah it was hunched over in the
chair a little bit weird uh hope
everyone has a good evening and has been
having a good week and has a good rest
of the week before the week's over I
need to go and replace my car Bunyan not
looking forward to that but I'll get
through it
I'll get through it looks tough stuff
but you're not alone you keep moving
forward and you are beautiful you are
valid you are loved you are the counsel
I just run meetings once a week live
with you folks in addition to all the
other videos that go up so hope everyone
is good until next time see you then I
had it all set but I missed the button
now I'm still standing and staring at
this thing